easy homemade spicy baked beans with
deliciously light potato cakes the first
big thing that I remember as a kid was
bacon and beans so this is like a little
rendition except we're using the most
amazing pancetta Ernie come on disappear
don't chase the mice now pat on get nice
and hot I'm gonna turn these beans into
glamorous beans pancetta into the pan
lightly seasoned that it's cured so it
doesn't need that much seasoning now
start firing off that pancetta it's
amazing how the individual taste of
baked beans they're somewhat bland so I
always like to make them a little bit
more spicy so a nice finely chopped
chili with the seeds chili in now a bit
of garlic crushed phenomenal
get that bacon really nice and crispy
fry off the chili and the garlic and
then onions my top tip for dicing finely
slice downwards slice across then cut
down to simply dice bacon onion chili
garlic that flavor all contained in that
little pan once you sweat the onion off
little bit of sugar in there the brown
sugar will start to caramelize darken
and enrich as well at the same time well
as beautiful now a couple of tablespoons
cider vinegar these lays of the pan it's
got that really nice powerful kick to it
now spice that up with one of my
favorite seasonings Worcester sauce
bring that to the boil and add your
starter puree tomatoes
[Music]
turn that down simmer the sauce to
reduce then add in the classic baked
bean haricot beans you can buy haricot
beans dried or canned they're packed
with protein and have a lovely soft
texture turn down the heat and let the
beans absorb all that beautiful spicy
tomato sauce and just let that simmer
now five or six minutes now for my
potato cakes they're a fantastic way to
use leftover ball potatoes and are so
easy to make I'm making a simple potato
dough by adding flour and butter to the
mash that gives it that nice sort of
cakey texture and it goes from this
leftover ball potato to there's nice
light flowery
potato heaven take a nice spoon of
potato lightly flour your board we're
gonna fry these crisp on the outside and
just nice and fluffy in the center now
do you pan nice and hot
we'll start off with olive oil into the
pan
put the butt around the outside because
it starts heating up the toilet goes
into the center so we're so nut-brown
gently turning over love that nice light
crisp little beautiful now take them out
Oh potato cake in the middle and a nice
beautiful spoon of beans growing up with
beans on toast as a treat still to this
day after all those years has not
changed my love or attitude for beans
especially good like that
[Music]
my smoky spicy homemade baked beans with
light and cream potato cakes comfort and
satisfaction on a plate
you